- People are gross,
especially when they eat.
(bag rustles)
(chip crunches)
(chewing)
(bubble gum popping)
(cookie crunching)
(simultaneous crunching and chewing)
- Wow, just love chips.
I love chips.
- Ew, oh no.
- I'm not grossed out for some reason
I just find it ew.
- I am very uncomfortable,
this feels so intimate.
No.
- I hate everything right now.
No, no, no.
I like that, I like the popping.
- Oh that sound.
- The sounds are terrible.
- Oh okay, that's, the hummus and carrots,
just, the graphic of it is pretty.
- Oh God close your mouth please.
- Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
It's more the visuals that got me rather
than the sounds really.
Actually it's both, I feel
like I want to throw up.
- (gags)
I always wondered why dates
were like food related
because ew hi we just met.
Gross.
- There was just a lot of
people eating wit their mouths
open and you know society tells you
(instrumental music)